[موسيقى]
بعزف نشيد الاتحاد الافريقي تنتهي اعمال
القمه السادسه والثلاثين والتي استمرت
يومين بيانها الختامي تضمن دعما كاملا
للشعب الفلسطيني في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وقرارات تطالب باصلاح مجلس
الامن الدولي ومنح افريقيا مقعدين دائمين
فيه وتحقيق الامن الغذائي لافريقيا اضافه
الى تقييم شامل لقضايا التنميه بالقاره مع
مرور عشر سنوات على رؤيه افريقيا لعام
على التكوين الشباب بحيث نتمكن من
الاعتماد على انفسنا مستقبلا في افريقيا
اليوم تصدر وفي الغطستورد من اجل
الاستهلاك ولكن ما نريده هو ان ننتج
ونستهلك ثم نصدر الصراعات المسلحه وظاهره
التطرف العنيف وعوده الانقلابات العسكريه
معضلات امنيه استح على نصيب كبير من
اجتماعات الرؤساء هذا العام لارتباطها
بتفاقم ظواهر اخرى كاللجوء والتدهور
الاقتصادي وانتهاكات حقوق الانسان لذا
شهدت القمه حزمه لقاءات موازيه للعمل على
وضع تسويات لهذه الصراعات
لقد حددنا لانفسنا هدفا طموحا لاسكات
البنادق ولتحقيقه يجب الا نتسامح مطلقا مع
النزاعات الحاليه والناشئه وان نضاعف
جهودنا لحل هذه السرعات يجب ان تكون هذه
هي المهمه التي نركز عليها لاجيال
المستقبل
اتفاقيه منطقه التجاره الحره الافريقيه
حلم لا يزال يراوح مكانه بسبب تباين
القوانين الوطنيه للدول مع احكام
الاتفاقيه سبب دفع الاتحاد الافريقي الى
رفع شعار تسريع تنفيذ منطقه التجاره الحره
الافريقيه في دورته لهذا العام عبر توفير
الدعم السياسي اللازم لتوحيد القوانين
الجمركيه والتشريعات التجاريه للسماح
للبضائع والسلع بالتحرك بانسيابيه بين دول
القاره دون تعقيدات هكذا انزل الستار على
القمه التي تزامنت مع انتهاء العقد الاول
من رؤيه افريقيا 2023
وسط توقعات بان يحمل العقد الثاني تحديات
اكبر بسبب حده التنافس الدولي على افريقيا
والانقلابات والتعثر التنميه فيما يؤكد
مراقبون ان التكامل بين الدول القاره هو
الحل الامثل للتقليل من مخ يعرف بقاره
الفرص الواعده حسن رزاق الجزيره من مقر
الاتحاد الافريقي اديس ابابا